6 42 put your pedal to the metal you can
take your own car on the oval at Las
Vegas Motor Speedway that sounds so cool
it's part of this weekend's lapse for
charity event hosted by Speedway
Children's Charities and our own Candace
Charles is live this morning there she
is running to the car and she's got the
need
for Speed Candace let's speed it up out
there what's going on you guys that's
why I'm trying to hurry up and get in
this car you guys are ready for a wild
wild ride I have here with me Kurt
Russell of the speedway Children's
Charities thanks for letting us hop into
your car here all right you ready let's
go let's get it going you guys want to
give you guys a little bit of taste of
what it's like here out on laps for
charity on Sunday we saw a bunch of
different cars out here I've seen uh
trucks all different types of vehicles
tell us a little bit about how people
can get involved in live for charity
absolutely I mean we have a lot of
events all throughout the year and this
is our kicking off the New Year here for
lab for charity I know you guys raised a
bunch of money for 63 Charities last
year what is your goal this year we hope
to raise even more money and to support
more people so you know certainly the
charity has done a lot of good in the
Las Vegas Community awesome awesome and
this is one awesome way to raise a
little bit more money for the community
thank you so much Kurt
I'm up on the hill guys you guys can
come on down here and enjoy the fun
yourself with your family you have to be
18 and over and of course have a license
to drive if you want to have your family
in there they can join as well but they
have to have everyone six and over to be
in the car as well and you can join for
just 75 bucks they ask you to
pre-register but you can also register
here on Sunday it all kicked off at 8
A.M we got you covered with the details
on our website 8newsnow.com for now live
from inside the vehicle on the Las Vegas
by the speedway we're NASCAR drivers
drive I'm Candace Charles it is now tell
Kurt to watch out for that wall that big
yellow thing on the side avoid hitting
that at all costs uh awesome live shot
Candice and shout out to our
photographer because that is an easy way
to get motion sickness
love that